with over one crore new jobs expected by
2026 and salaries ranging from 5 lakhs
to 40 lakhs per annum
data science is arguably the number one
career choice today i'm anan narinen
chief product officer of simply learn
the world's number one online bootcamp
now welcome you to the data science job
guarantee program
this program offers you the best
opportunity to master the most sought
after skills in data science and get an
assured job within six months of course
completion no matter what your career
goals are our data science job guarantee
boot camp is there for assured career
success
how is it different from other programs
out there with a learning path designed
by the best in industry and suitable for
learners with technical as well as
non-technical backgrounds it moves from
the basic principles to advanced
techniques tools and languages including
statistics data analysis modeling data
visualization machine learning deep
learning neural networks sqlr python and
much more as you attend and complete
each session delivered live online the
program lets you practice and perfect
the skills learned on integrated live
virtual labs
you gain real mastery with 30 industry
aligned projects and one guided capstone
where you'll use the knowledge gained to
solve real business problems which in
turn will help you build up your
business acumen but that's not all
the program offers a pro membership to
hire us.com which includes job placement
assistance resume enhancements interview
preparation plus one-on-one mock
interviews you also get access to the
best career mentors and industry leaders
enhance your profile and become job
ready for data science jobs at companies
like amazon linkedin microsoft ibm
goldman sachs pwc unilever airbus and
many others
at the end of it all you'll walk away
with a globally recognized skill set and
a job guaranteed within just six months
if not get a 100 refund no questions
asked that's the promise join us for the
next cohort apply now